>> Bill: THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT IN WASHINGTON CITING THE
WAR IN UKRAINE TO PUSH HIS GREEN
AND IT'S THE POLICY.
THE FOLLOWING IS A QUOTE FROM
THE OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE
TRANSCRIPT.
HERE'S ONE QUOTE HERE.
"RUSSIA AND UKRAINE IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE NEED TO GET OFF OF
OUR DEPENDENCY ON FOSSIL FUELS.
IMAGINE WE WOULD BE RIGHT NOW
IF, IN FACT, EUROPE WAS ENERGY
FREE OF FOSSIL FUELS AND WAS --
IT WAS ALL RENEWABLES.
IT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT WORLD."
IT IS 2022 AND KARL ROVE HAS
THOUGHTS ON THIS.
GOOD MORNING.
IF IT WERE 2042, MAY BE MAKE AN
ARGUMENT LIKE THAT.
YOU SAW THE TRANSCRIPT FROM
THIS.
I READ IT AS WELL.
WHAT YOU MAKE FROM IT QUESTION
WORKS BECAUSE THIS IS A
DANGEROUS TERRITORY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO VENTURE IN.
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR THE FACTS TO
BE TOLD THE TRUTH.
THEY
WANT TO BE TOLD WHY THESE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING.
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED A YEAR OF
INFLATION.
THEY KNOW THAT WHAT THEY'RE
PAYING AT THE PUMP AND PAYING AT
THE GROCERY STORE IS NOT THE
RESULT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT IS THE RESULT OF THE POLICIES
OF THIS GOVERNMENT.
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS SHOWS WHY IN THE
LATEST ABC POLL, 70% DISAPPROVE
OF BIDEN'S HANDLING OF
INFLATION.
INFLATION IS LOOMING AS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE COME ECONOMIC
ISSUE, HERE AT HOME IN 2022 AND
THE BIGGEST ISSUE WITH THE
POLLS.
>> Bill: MORE POLLING.
IT SHOWS AMERICANS GOING
SIDEWAYS ON THIS.
WHAT IS THE OBSESSION WITH
CLIMATE WHEN CHINA CONTINUES TO
BURN MORE COAL?
WHAT IS THE OBSESSION QUESTION
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT PUTIN IS
RAISING CLIMATE CHANGE ANY
SUMMITS?
>> WE ARE THE ONLY MAJOR
INDUSTRIALIZED ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD THAT IS SIMULTANEOUS TO
GROWING ITS ECONOMY AND REDUCING
THE ABSOLUTE LEVEL OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
CHINA IS NOT OBLIGATED TO START
REDUCING ITS ANNUAL ADMISSIONS
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS TO COME.
SAME WITH INDIA.
I REPEAT, WE'RE THE ONLY MAJOR
INDUSTRIALIZED ECONOMY
SIMULTANEOUSLY GROWING AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
WE'VE BEEN DOING DOING IT FOR
DECADES.
THIS IS DANGEROUS TERRITORY FOR
THE PRESENT.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
NEW ECONOMISTS POLL.
BIDEN SAYS WHAT HE BELIEVES.
36%.
SAYS WHAT HE THINKS PEOPLE WANT
TEMP TO HEAR, 47%.
18% ARE UNDECIDED.
EITHER HE IS JUST TELLING US
WHAT HE THINKS WE WANT TO HEAR
OR I'M LEANING AGAINST HIM.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PLACE FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO BEAT.
WHEN A PRESIDENT LOSES HIS
CREDIBILITY, HE BEGINS TO BE
SEEN AS A WEEK LATER.
IN THE SEINE ECONOMIST PAUL, A Y
STRONG LEADER.
13%.
SOMEWHAT STRONG, 24.
VERY WEAK, 43%.
IT'S HARD TO REVERSE THEM.
THE PRESIDENT HAS GREETED THE
PROBLEM FOR HIMSELF BY NOT
SHOOTING THROUGH THIS.
LAST YEAR THAT TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE, GASOLINE PRICES DROPPED
3%.
THEY HAVE GROWN 43% FROM JANUARY
OF 2022 JANUARY OF 2022.
WE HAVE LIVED THROUGH THIS.
WE ARE LIVING THROUGH IT IN OUR
REAL LIVES.
WHEN WE DOUBT THE PRESIDENT, HE
BECOMES A WEAKER LEADER IN OUR
EYES.
SPEW AND YOU ABOUT BLAMING PUTIN
AND INFLATION.
BUT THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS.
ON THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT, THAT IS
WHERE YOU GET FUND-RAISING.
SPEAK OUT THAT IS WHERE YOU GET
ENTHUSIASM.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE SAME
POLLS AND THEY'RE FINDING OUT
THAT HE HAS A PROBLEM WITH
SUBURBAN VOTERS AND A PROBLEM
WITH INDEPENDENTS AND A PROBLEM
WITH HIS OWN BASE OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT AFTER HE
PROMISED TO BE A
TRANSFORMATIONAL PRESIDENT.
AFTER RUNNING AS THE NORMAL GUY
IN THE ELECTION, THEY GOT
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE GUY THEY
SAW IN OFFICE.
HE REACHED THEIR EXPECTATIONS
AND HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DELIVER.
PEOPLE INSIDE HIS PARTY OR
SAYING WEEK LATER.
HE HAS PROBLEMS ALL OVER THE
BOARD.
TRYING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM WITH
INDEPENDENCE AND SUBURBAN SWING
VOTERS.
HE HAS DECIDED HE'S GOING TO
PLAY TO THE BASE.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING TO THE BASE
FOR A YEAR AND A QUARTER AND IT
HAS NOT WORKED.
WHY DOES HE THINK IT'S GOOD TO
CHANGE OUT?
>> Bill: MATTER WHERE WE WOULD
BE IF EUROPE WAS FOR HIS FOSSIL
FUELS.